Prof: Okay,
today I have put up a slide
from the first lecture,
just as a signpost and landmark
to make sure that you're
oriented on the path through the
course.
Basically the material we cover
before Spring Break is organized
into these large sections,
and today we're making the
transition from microevolution
to macroevolution.
And you'll recall that in
microevolution we had six
lectures on microevolutionary
principles,
and then we had five lectures,
that we just completed last
time,
on how phenotypes,
organisms, how they're designed
for reproductive success.
We're now going to make the
transition into
macroevolutionary principles,
with the process that connects
microevolution to
macroevolution,
and that is speciation.
So as we now move into
macroevolution,
today's talk is really mostly
about speciation.
Then we will,
next time, have a talk about
phylogenetics and systematics,
and then about how you can use
the combination of these
principles to look at
evolutionary trees and to place
them on maps,
and then to place the evolution
of traits onto trees and onto
maps,
so that you can integrate space
and time,
and history.
Then we have three ways of
looking at the history of life.
The first is more abstract,
I think a little bit deeper,
and that has to do with key
events in evolution:
origin of life,
multi-cellularity,
language, things like that.
We'll have a review of major
events in the geological
theater.
For those of you that like
firecrackers on the Fourth of
July that's fun,
because that's where we have
meteorite impacts and
extinctions and stuff like that.
And then we'll take a look at
the fossil record and what it-
the kinds of unique insights
that you can get out of fossils
that you really can't get out of
just looking at living
organisms.
So those are three different
ways to approach the issue of
the history of life.
Okay, today speciation.
I would hope that by the end of
today's lecture and the end of
your reading and discussion in
section about this,
that you would be able to deal
with this set of issues.
What is a species?
How do they originate?
What kinds of experimental
evidence or observational
evidence do we have to back up
the claims about how they
originate?
What's going on during
speciation, from the point of
view of genetics;
if we track the genes through
the process of speciation,
what do we see?
And then there are some special
issues: asexual species and
cryptic species.
I would like to signal that
this is a part of biology in
which some of your teaching
fellows have special expertise.
So if you would like to get to
the cutting edge of phylogenetic
research,
you have got some people in
section who can help you,
and this department happens to
be particularly good at that.
There was a front page report
in the New York- well on
the Science Page of the New
York Times,
in their Darwin Section,
they were reporting on Stephen
Smith's Ph.D.
thesis.
He just got his degree here
last year.
But he assembled the largest
Tree of Life for the plants.
So we've got people like that
running around,
and you ought to tap into them,
if you feel the urge.
Okay?
Now here is a basic
observation, and it is one of
those things that just seems so
natural to us that it doesn't
occur at first sight to ask how
it might be that way.
But in fact it is a puzzle.
We have wild diversity in the
world.
Please forgive me botanists.
I had some help assembling this
slide.
I would like to have had a few
more neat plants in there;
there are some incredibly neat
plants that could go in there.
But if we just look at the
world, it's amazingly diverse.
Okay?
So we look out there and
there's lots of different kinds
of organisms,
and they seem to be in discrete
groups,
separated from other such
groups, and in many ways:
appearance,
behavior, ecology, genetics.
So why is the world like this?
How did that come about?
Why is the planet not simply
covered with a homogenous layer
of primordial slime,
rather than these different
things?
For a long time it wasn't that
way really.
The prokaryotic world was
genetically diverse,
but it certainly didn't have
this kind of morphological
diversity in it.
Well those things that are
separated are called species,
and this is the guy who
profoundly influenced this kind
of biology.
His name's Ernst Mayr.
Ernst died a few years ago at
the age of 100-and-something.
So he managed to keep active
for a very long time.
I knew him.
He was an impressive guy and he
had an almost unprecedented
ability to claim that he had
already said it.
Now his definition of what a
species is--
this is from a version of a
book that he wrote in 1963,
but he had been working on this
idea from about 1942,
and his idea was that a species
is a group of actually or
potentially inter-breeding
natural populations that are
reproductively isolated from
other such groups.
So it's the capacity for
reproducing together that unites
the members of a species,
and it's the inability or the
lack of opportunity to reproduce
with individuals of other
populations that marks the
separation between species;
according to Mayr.
Now there were very good
reasons for this definition,
and it really captures the
essence of genetic separation.
But there are cases where it
doesn't apply.
As a matter of fact,
I think that biology has a
profound capacity to erode the
categories invented by humans.
>
There are almost always
exceptions.
To that, I would like to add
that Ernst Mayr was a great
ornithologist,
and that the kinds of patterns
you see in species,
in birds, were what motivated
him to come up with this
definition,
and if he had been a plant
biologist he probably wouldn't
have defined things this way.
Okay?
Now just something to think
about.
Does everything really have to
belong to a species?
Would there be some itch that
you needed to be scratched if
not everything belonged to a
species?
Would that make you unhappy for
some reason?
I'm going to let that one hang
in the air.
Okay, now when we look out
there and we see that things are
separated,
there are some pretty
straightforward mechanisms that
actually separate things,
and so this is part of the
vocabulary building exercise for
speciation science;
and it's also a little bit of
biology.
There are isolating mechanisms
that are common,
they fall into three
categories, and they look a
little different in plants and
animals.
The first category is
pre-mating or pre-zygotic
isolation,
and in plants that's often
determined--
not always but often--by
pollinator behavior and
flowering times,
and in animals it is determined
by mating behavior and gamete
release.
So here we have actually a
place where sexual selection,
from the last lecture,
connects into speciation,
because who you choose as your
mate is going to determine
whether there's an opportunity
for inter-specific hybridization
or not.
So this is actually an issue
about mate choice,
which is kind of at a higher
hierarchical level than the
issue of should I choose my mate
for resources or good genes or
sexy sons or something like
that?
Should I choose a mate,
because in mating with that
individual I will form hybrids
or I will form members of my own
species?
In a minute you'll see some
pollinator behavior slides;
so just to anticipate that.
It is quite possible for plants
to be separated just by
flowering time.
Imagine a valley that's running
east-west,
in a temperate area of the
planet, and it is getting sun
earlier on one slope than on the
other,
simply because of the angle of
the sun to the earth.
Everything's going to speed up
on the warm slope and slow down
on the cold slope,
and you're going to get
different flowering times for
purely biophysical reasons,
on the two slopes.
So initially a plant population
might come in after maybe the
glacier has melted off and
colonize those two slopes,
and they wouldn't be able to
avoid having different flowering
times,
and therefore starting to
separate genetically on the two
slopes.
So there are all kinds of
reasons for separation to start.
Now the second class of
isolating mechanisms occurs a
bit later;
it's post-pollination or after
insemination.
And in plants there are--and
actually in many algae and
ciliates--there are
self-incompatibility mechanisms.
These are actually put in place
through recognition molecules.
And there is an
interesting--gamete biology is
very interesting.
There's a lot of mate choice
which is going on at the level
of the sperm finding the egg and
the egg sitting there and
deciding,
"Do I want this one or
not?"
Throw that one away and take
another one.
And these are mediated by well
understood enzymatic reactions
and protein structures;
bindin and lysine.
The self-incompatibility
argument in plants basically has
to do with the costs of
inbreeding, and the costs of
selfing.
And the arena in which that
takes place is after the pollen
grain lands on the style of the
flower and starts to grow down
the style,
towards the ovary of the
flower, the tissues that are in
the style are checking out that
particular pollen grain,
which is making basically a
little plant-like thing,
as it grows down towards the
eggs, and that is where the
self-recognition is implemented.
If its pollen is coming from
that same plant,
it'll get killed at that point.
So there are post-pollination
and post-insemination mechanisms
of isolation.
Now after fertilization occurs,
post-zygotic isolating
mechanisms basically have to do
with viability,
survival and fertility.
So hybrid inviability or
infertility is a common thing,
once two species have diverged
to a certain extent.
And of course the commonest one
that you're probably all
familiar with is the mule;
the mule is a cross between a
donkey and a horse,
and mules are sterile.
So hybridization between
donkeys and horses isn't going
to go anywhere evolutionarily
because there are never any
grandchildren.
I believe the same is true for
ligers, crosses between lions
and tigers.
I'm getting nods from the
zoological aficionados in the
audience.
So thank you for the
confirmation.
However, at this stage,
often fairly distantly related
plants are able to hybridize.
It's usually not across the
boundaries of genera or
families,
but sometimes you can get
plants from two genera
hybridizing with each other,
which may be an indication that
the classification has been
wrong.
But plants generally hybridize
a lot more easily than animals
do,
and it may have something to do
with the differences in their
developmental complexity.
Usually the reasons for hybrid
inviability in animals are
developmental abnormalities.
Okay, so I had signaled that we
were going to look at a
pre-zygotic example.
So here is species separation
by pollinator recognition.
Here are two columbine species,
and they can overlap
geographically.
You'll notice that they really
have very different colors,
and that is actually related to
the brains of the things that
pollinate them.
Yes, moths do have brains.
Okay?
So hummingbirds are notorious
among pollination biologists for
loving red and yellow,
and if you see a white flower,
you can normally--
it's a pretty good bet that
it's going to be pollinated by a
moth or a bat.
And in fact if you were to look
at these things in the
ultraviolet,
you would probably see that
there were,
in the ultraviolet,
interesting markings on them,
and often flowers that have
ultraviolet markings on them are
bee pollinated,
because bees see particularly
well in the ultraviolet.
So these are two species that
are separated by pollinator
behavior,
and I invite you to play
through a scenario in your mind
of how their ancestor had the
same color and then how they
might have gotten different.
Okay?
It would've been a gradual
step-wise process,
as they specialized on a
particular pollinator.
Okay, so species can be
separated by various mechanisms
and at various stages in the
process of reproduction.
Mayr gave us a biological
species concept;
that's the biological species
concept, isolation.
And there are plenty of others
now.
And I've put this list up here,
not for you to memorize,
but more or less--I do invite
you to go through and sample
these species concepts--
but to show you that actually
to try to state logically what
we mean when we say the word
species has been a
difficult task for phylogenetic
biologists to deal with,
and the fact that I can put a
list like this up there is a
measure of the difficulty,
and a measure of the
controversy and the disagreement
that has occurred over this
issue.
What each of these definitions
does is try to define a species
from a slightly different
biological starting point.
And what they're trying to do
essentially is get the most
general and useful definition
that they can.
And in some way they all fail,
which is kind of neat,
because it means there's still
work to be done,
but in some way they're also
all partially correct.
So I told you about Mayr's
concept.
The recognition concept
basically is based on mating
systems.
So species are things that will
decide to mate with each other;
that's Hugh Patterson's.
The phylogenetic species
concept--there are various ways
of looking at the Tree of Life
and deciding what on it
constitutes a species.
So Joel Cracraft said it's a
cluster or organisms that are
distinct from other such
clusters, within which there's a
pattern of ancestry or descent.
So he says well essentially
it's the stuff that's out there
at the tip, that's closely
associated.
Back in '78 Wiley said that a
species is a lineage of
ancestor-descent populations
that maintains its identity from
other such lineages and has its
own evolutionary tendencies and
historical fate.
I don't know why he had to put
the last phrases in;
it kind of messes up the idea a
little bit.
But essentially if you're
looking at a phylogenetic tree,
what he's saying is there's a
start and a finish on a branch.
So it has duration through time;
that kind of thing.
And then we'll come back to the
genetic cluster species concept,
which is one that Jim Mallet
put forth.
Basically it says if you can
get a lot of genetic data on the
things that you're looking at,
and you plot them out into gene
space somehow,
and you find that they form
distinct clusters,
then each separate cluster is a
separate species.
Now each of these is useful in
a somewhat different context.
And, as I said,
I think that they all get at
parts of what we mean when we
say the word species.
And I don't want you to forget
the question I have hanging in
the air, which is do we have to
make everything into a species?
Okay?
So, concepts and criteria.
This I know looks a little
weird.
Okay?
Why do they distinguish between
concepts and criteria?
Because after all criteria are
concepts.
Okay?
This is because they were
trying to achieve kind of a
local clarity in what they were
talking about.
So the concepts are more or
less general statements about
how you might go about thinking
about what a species is,
and the criteria are rules of
thumb to decide whether a thing
is a species or not.
So you can think of the
concepts as being abstract and
the criteria being practical.
So we've got these concepts.
And here are a few criteria
that could be applied to any
concept.
So one would be,
why are the things separated?
Is there initial separation?
And of course if we want to go
into it, we can look at the
causes, but maybe the most
important thing is just that
they're separated,
not why.
We can look at whether the
species is cohesive in some
sense;
there are different definitions
of cohesion, but one is,
is there genetic mixture?
Are they breeding with each
other?
So cohesion has something to do
with the biological species
concept.
Another is, is that--are the
organisms in the populations
that we're looking at
monophyletic?
I'm going to come to the
definition of monophyly today,
and I'm going to repeat it next
time, so that it gets hammered
in a little bit.
But basically that means do
they all share a common
ancestor?
And then there's the issue of
distinguishability;
can we actually tell them apart?
Now when we get down to cryptic
species, at the end of the
lecture, you'll see that they
are indistinguishable,
except at the genetic level.
We can't look at them and see
any difference.
But for many things these will
be useful criteria.
So, monophyly.
The things in monophyletic
groups share a common ancestor,
and that common ancestor is not
the ancestor of any other group,
and there aren't any things
that are descended from that
ancestor that aren't in this
group.
Okay?
So it's really everything that
came from that common ancestor.
So birds all appear to have
shared a common ancestor that
split off from basically a group
of dinosaurs,
back in the Cretaceous;
possibly a little earlier,
in the Jurassic.
Mammals all split off earlier
from a group of organisms whose
later descendents then included
the dinosaurs,
but also many other things in
that grade.
In contrast to a monophyletic
group,
a paraphyletic group is a group
that doesn't contain all the
things that are descended from
the most recent common ancestor
of its members.
Okay?
So yes, everything in here has
a common ancestor,
but hey, there's some other
things that descended from that
common ancestor that are out
here.
So, for example,
if you call fish a natural
group,
you're making a mistake because
the tetrapods are descended from
the same ancestors as the
ancestors of everything you want
to call a fish.
So the amphibians,
the reptiles--I'll come to the
reptiles in a minute
>
--the birds and the mammals are
also things that we ought to
call fish--okay?--by that
definition.
So we need a different word to
reflect the history of
relationship.
In the reptiles,
the birds and the mammals are
missing.
Okay?
So if we say reptile,
and we want to really refer
accurately to a Tree of Life,
a good phylogenetic tree,
then that word should actually
also mean,
oh, we mean the birds and the
mammals too.
The thing that's going on here
is that our everyday language
culturally evolved before our
scientific discoveries
demonstrated what the natural
relationships of groups were,
and therefore we have embedded
in our everyday language
mistakes.
So that's why these
distinctions have been drawn.
They are pointers to mistakes.
So if somebody says
paraphyletic,
it's like that's a mistake.
Then we have polyphyletic,
which is another kind of a
mistake,
and a group is
polyphyletic--the word referring
to that group is a mistake--
if the things in it are
descended from several ancestors
that are also the ancestors of
things that are classified into
other groups.
So, for example,
all the stuff that Linniaeus
called worms was highly
polyphyletic.
It included the mollusks.
It included therefore the
octopuses and the squid.
If you were to refer to the Old
World Euphorbiaceae and the New
World Cactaceae,
among the plants,
as being in the same group
because they look the same,
you would be wrong,
because they both have--
they're actually fairly
distantly related from each
other and they have converged on
Cactus-like forms,
and they have closest relatives
that don't look anything like a
Cactus.
So if you ever make a group
like that, that would be
polyphyletic.
Are there any questions about
these three distinctions,
or have I managed to get across
those differences clearly
enough?
Because this is--it's important;
it's simple but it's important.
Okay, species concepts and
criteria were reconciled by
Kevin De Queiroz,
and basically what Kevin did
was more or less arrive on a
scene where people had been
embroiled in controversy over
species concepts,
and he wanted to kind of stop
all of the squabbling about the
concepts and try to move the
research on by more or less
trying to resolve that,
and do so in a constructive way.
He did a pretty good job.
Basically he said, "Hey,
let's see if we can agree--not
everybody does--
but let's see if we can agree
that species are entire
population level segments of
lineages,
from origination to
extinction."
So they have duration in time,
and they're at the level of a
population, and we could map
them onto a Tree of Life.
And the criteria aren't the
same as concepts.
Basically what they're doing is
they're marking stages in the
existence of a species,
and they don't actually
determine whether the species is
a species yet.
Okay?
Now, as we'll see,
if you actually go through
what's going on as a species
starts to evolve,
on the Tree of Life,
and you mark off these species
criteria,
I think you'll see that much of
the time,
by the time you've stepped
through all your criteria,
you have a good species.
Okay.
What are they?
Well there's separation.
There's cohesion,
and the cohesion can be genetic
and caused by actual or
potential interbreeding.
It can be cohesion of
recognition;
so everybody who is a potential
mate can recognize each other as
a potential mate.
It can be a cohesion of
viability and fertility.
So there's post-zygotic
compatibility;
very important to include a lot
of plant species there.
Then there can be ecological
cohesion.
So these things are living in
the same habitat,
at the same time,
behaving as an ecological unit,
and very probably doing so
because they are actually
inter-breeding.
By the way, this business of
remaining separate,
in the same place,
is a good criterion for two
separate species.
So if you see two things that
are remaining separate,
even though they are
continually running into each
other in the same time and
place,
then that's a pretty good
indication that they're separate
species.
So another criterion is
monophyly;
so they share a single most
recent common ancestor.
And then you can distinguish
them either through fixed
morphological differences or as
a phenotypic cluster in
phenotype space--
this is a more quantitative
thing than the quantum
differences of distinct
morphology--
or they could be a genotypic
cluster,
in a genotype space.
Now when you think--I'm now
going to lead up to a bit on the
genetics of speciation,
and this slide is intended as a
transition into that,
and it is intended to show you
basically that gene trees often
differ from population trees.
So what's going to go on in a
speciation event is that you're
coming along the Tree of Life
and there's going to be a split
and there are going to be two
new branches.
And these are entire
populations down here.
Okay?
So you should think of each
branch down here as having
thousands of organisms in it.
And what these lines are
showing you is that there are
splits in gene trees that can
start occurring before the
population splits,
and that can continue to occur
after the population splits.
And what we mean by a gene tree
split is actually a couple of
possibilities.
One is, okay,
a mutation occurs here at a
locus,
and we now have two different
alleles that are in this
population,
and these two different alleles
then can continue to be
maintained by various processes,
and one of them ends up going
down this branch,
and then the descendents of
this one end up going down this
branch.
That's one possibility.
Another possibility is,
oh, we have a gene duplication
even here;
so we now have two different
versions of the gene.
They both are being used for
something.
They're functional,
they don't become pseudo-genes
necessarily,
and the descendents of one
copy--actually in that case you
ought to get both copies going
down both branches of the gene
duplication event.
So that would probably be more
like this.
I suppose that it's conceivable
actually that you could lose a
copy and still have functional
organisms,
if the process of acquiring
function for the second copy was
still going on in this region of
time here.
At any rate,
the point here is that if you
look back to try to find the
last common ancestor of
different genes,
or different alleles,
it's quite possible that that
last common ancestor for the
genes will be deeper in time
than the last common ancestor of
the species;
and that's because species have
lots of genes.
Okay?
So if we look at that kind of
process, here is a separation
point where, after this,
each of these branches is going
to be monophyletic.
At this point some of the genes
have become fixed.
So by showing that this one is
gone over here--
that's just intended as a
symbol, an analogy,
to indicate that a gene has
become fixed--
and over here in this lineage
maybe some other one has become
fixed,
and at that point genetically
these species are
distinguishable.
You can tell them apart because
now one lineage has one version
of a gene, and the other lineage
has another.
Then as these genetic
differences accumulate,
later in time they will be
reproductively isolated from
each other.
If two individuals of the two
species did meet,
they would not be able to have
viable grandchildren.
And of course I've shown you
that that reproductive isolation
can occur at three different
stages.
It's likely that the sequence
in which reproductive isolation
is acquired is actually the
reverse of the sequence that I
laid it out.
So it would be first
post-zygotic isolation;
then post-fertilization
isolation;
and then finally pre-zygotic
isolation, with recognition that
the two things are different.
Okay?
And then finally up here,
no hybridization at all is
possible and you have complete
genetic isolation.
So you would think that this
might be--
with reproductive isolation
that you wouldn't get any
hybrids,
but there could be a few
mistakes, and so finally
complete gene exclusion is
usually coming after what is in
practice reproductive isolation.
This is a bit imperfect.
So if we look into the genome,
and this has been done best
with Drosophila,
because it's such a good model
organism--
and this is,
if you want to go into this
kind of thing,
search under C.I. Wu,
that's Chung-I Wu;
he's at Chicago.
And basically what Chung-I said
was that if we look across a
genome--
okay, so you can think of A,
B and C just being as markers
on the genome--
there's gene flow between two
populations at lots of places in
the genome as speciation just is
starting to get going.
Okay?
So at this stage we have
populations or races.
They've got perhaps different
kinds of adaptations.
There isn't any reproductive
isolation, and between these
three loci there's lots of
recombination;
the three loci are actually
capable of moving back and
forth.
So A and a can move back and
forth;
B and b, and so forth.
Then, in the second stage,
there starts to be some block
to gene exchange,
and here we are at a level
where we're getting a transition
between a race and a species,
or between a race and
sub-species, with some degree of
reproductive isolation,
and at this stage the
populations could fuse or they
could diverge.
But these blocks here,
that you're seeing,
are indicating portions of the
genome where there isn't any
exchange anymore.
So the idea here is that the
origin of reproductive
isolation, if you look at the
genetic level,
is a gradual process;
it doesn't occur all at once.
It starts in parts of the
genome, and it continues,
and while it is developing,
there's some still some gene
exchange going on,
at certain loci.
And you might think--and I
think this is probably the
case--
the parts where the exchange is
still going on are the parts
that aren't having big impact on
hybrid inviability or mate
recognition.
The parts that are starting to
get frozen up are the parts that
have to do with any of those
three levels of separation.
So when reproductive isolation
is complete, then all of the
genes are free to diverge.
So here the populations are
beyond the point where they
could fuse but--
and they're a good species--but
there's a still little bit of
hybridization going on,
that you can pick up,
and here they're completely
separated and there's no gene
flow anymore.
Now Chung-I did this actually
with simulans,
Drosophila simulans,
Drosophila mauritania,
and the two sexual races of
Drosophila melanagaster,
which are in Africa.
Okay?
And he looked through the
genomes of these species to see
at how many places were there
genes that were diverging,
and what were those genes
coding for?
So the differences between the
two sexual races of Drosophila
melanagaster,
which are really quite recently
separated--
we're talking perhaps 50 or
100,00 years here--
are all in sexual behavior.
That's things like how fast
does the male vibrate his wings?
And Stage 3,
which is about here,
is between simulans and
mauritania, and here we're
starting to get back maybe
500,000 years,
something like that;
and here we're starting to pick
up lots of sterility and
inviability or female sterility
genes,
and changes in genital
morphology so that lock/key
mechanisms are incompatible.
And then finally when you get
this divergence here,
which is back at one to two
million years,
basically you just see a lot
more genes in these categories;
sterility and inviability
accumulate.
So how does a new species
actually come into existence?
Well going from that rather
modern evolutionary genetics,
back a bit to the arguments in
the '40s,
'50s and '60s over speciation,
a lot of that argument is about
geographic speciation.
Darwin emphasized allopatric
speciation.
Gulick, who worked on the
speciation of snails in Hawaii
and Polynesia,
emphasized allopatric
speciation.
Sympatric and parapatric
speciation are things that came
in, in the '60s and '70s.
Allopatric means allo-patric,
different places;
sym-patric, same place;
para-patric, next to each other.
And genetically,
as you've seen from Chung-I
Wu's analysis,
initially there are only a few
genes that are changing.
So even though you have 35,000
genes in the genome,
speciation might be driven by
four or five,
and that's what might allow it
to occur fairly quickly.
And then after reproductive
isolation, the changes in those
genes mean that all the others
will diverge.
So a good criterion for a
species is,
as I told you,
they remain separate when
they're living in the same place
and encountering each other at
the same place and the same
time.
So let's take a look
schematically at what these
terms mean.
So in allopatric speciation you
have an original population.
There's some geographic or
geological barrier that forms.
They then start to diverge in
isolation--
so here they just start having
different colors--
and then after they might come
back together they won't breed
again,
because they've diverged so
much.
So the classical large-scale
example of this is the ratite
birds.
Those are the flightless birds
of the Southern continents,
and they include the Ostrich,
the Cassowary,
the Emu, the Kiwi,
the Elephant Bird of
Madagascar,
the Moas of New Zealand.
And arguably those are all
birds that originated from a
common ancestor that was on
Gondwana,
and when Gondwana broke up
through plate tectonics,
these just rode around on the
plates.
They never flew and they never
swam.
Okay?
So they were actually carried
on pieces of rock into different
places.
There are, by the way,
many other things that can form
barriers.
Mountain ranges can go up,
and when they do,
river basins can change,
drainage basins can change.
Things can become
reproductively isolated when
they fly out to an oceanic
island, and so forth.
Now parapatric speciation means
next door, right next door.
So some individuals of a
population get up and they move
and they just go right next
door.
This is thought to have been
actually how the Galapagos
finches might have speciated on
a single island.
So some of them might have
simply gone up the mountain,
while others stayed down on the
coast.
That would be parapatric
speciation.
It is also thought to have been
what has driven the speciation
of frogs in the Eastern United
States, and is still in the
process of going on.
So, for example,
in the Leopard Frog,
on the East Coast of the United
States,
you can breed individuals from
Connecticut and New York and
they do just fine.
Now that frog has a range that
goes from Canada to Georgia,
and if you try to breed
individuals from Quebec with
individuals from Georgia,
they won't.
But all along the way you can
make the crosses,
which means that it is possible
in principle for a gene from
Quebec to end up in Georgia.
So according to the biological
species definition,
it's a species,
but in fact it's in the process
of splitting up.
Okay?
And by the way,
this pattern is something that
got re-established after the
glaciers melted.
So the frogs moved north,
and this pattern has gotten set
up in the last 12,000 years,
about.
Oh, I should go back and do
these guys.
Okay, that's parapatric and
this is sympatric.
Sympatric is particularly
interesting because the
controversy over this was so
violent and it involved some of
Ernst Mayr's Ph.D.
students rebelling against Mayr;
so that was Guy Bush.
And basically the idea behind
sympatric speciation is that
it's possible for a population,
where all of the organisms are
living in the same general place
and encountering each other at
the same general times,
to split according to
ecological processes that are
going on in that little area.
The initial example was a fruit
fly that switched from living on
apples to living on cherries,
where the apple trees and the
cherry trees were all in the
same orchard,
And because the offspring were
imprinted on the smell of the
fruit in which they grew up,
when they grew up,
they tended to go to that same
kind of fruit,
and because mating took place
on the surface of the fruit,
they became reproductively
isolated and they started to
diverge.
The name of this one is
Rhagoletis, and its sympatric
speciation has actually been
documented and followed,
and it's occurring in Michigan.
You'll see later,
we have an example from fish in
African lakes where it looks
like this is going on.
Now pushing experimental
evolution from questions of
microevolution into questions of
macroevolution is not easy,
because by definition
macroevolution describes
phenomena that are taking place
over longer periods of time.
Nevertheless,
there have been attempts to
cause speciation to happen in
the laboratory.
They have mostly been with
short-lived fruit flies,
and I'd just like to summarize
some of that experimental
evidence so that you can see how
close people have come to
actually being able to create
new species in the lab.
If you do divergent selection
in allopatry--
so you split a population in
two and you don't let any gene
flow occur between them,
and then you select strongly on
one trait in one direction in
one population,
and in the other direction in
the other--
you can actually cause
reproductive isolation to
evolve;
you can do that in a couple of
hundred generations.
If you select them in the same
direction in allopatry,
that doesn't seem to work.
If you destroy the hybrids,
when they are in sympatry,
and you divergently select in
sympatry, that usually works.
So you can start the speciation
process in the lab,
in sympatry,
by destroying any hybrids
between the two things that
you're trying to make diverge,
and selecting those two things
in different directions,
morphologically.
But if you divergently select
without destroying hybrids,
that almost never works.
Okay?
So there is an experimental
biology of speciation,
and there is a literature on
that.
This is something that's
particularly been done in Spain,
by the way.
Now recently there has been
some recent evolutionary theory
on whether or not sympatric
speciation is possible,
and it does appear that it's
possible,
and it can occur rapidly if you
have divergent selection to
different habitats,
and you couple that with
preferential mating with your
own ecological type.
So this kind of thinking has
mostly been applied to fish,
and it's been applied to
sticklebacks living in lakes in
British Columbia,
and it has been applied to
cichlids living in lakes in
Africa.
Let's take a look at some
cichlids in Africa.
So here are two cichlids that
are recently derived from the
same common ancestor and often
classified into the same
species.
They are Tilapia.
They're living in a lake in
Cameroon.
This is male size versus female
size, and so you can see that
there are basically two clusters
with a few intermediates.
There are some little males and
females,
and there are some big males
and females,
and you tend to find the small
ones in deep water and the big
ones in shallow water.
And if you look at the
frequency with which you find
them in deep and shallow,
you can see that you only get
the small ones in deep water,
and there are a few of the big
ones in deep water,
but most of the big ones are in
shallow water.
You'll notice--by the way,
it's darker in deeper water,
and you'll notice that the ones
that are the small ones living
in deeper water already are
evolving bigger eyes,
and there's starting to be some
reproductive isolation between
these.
So this is a circumstance in
which there is a different
ecological habitat;
there are different foraging
and sensory specializations that
are needed in the deep habitat
than in the shallow habitat.
These guys are probably feeding
on snails on the bottom,
and these are probably feeding
on plankton in mid-water.
There is good reason for these
two not to cross,
because the intermediate
phenotypes aren't nearly as
good;
okay, they aren't ecologically
as good, they don't perform as
well in eating snails or in
foraging for zooplankton.
So that's sort of the classical
ecological speciation
hypothesis.
Dolph Schluter at British
Columbia has written a whole
book on this.
There's a big literature on it,
and a lot of people are
interested in the idea that
there could be some sympatric
speciation going on.
Now we saw that these species
criteria work fairly well for a
certain range of organisms,
but then there's also the
genotypic cluster thing,
and that really solves a
problem with asexual and cryptic
species.
So I'd like to just introduce
you to that issue.
One context where it's useful
actually is with bacteria.
So here are a whole bunch of
bacteria that all live in the
gut, enteric bacteria,
gut flora.
And these guys are all pretty
proficient at horizontal gene
exchange.
There's about 30% of their
genome that they exchange back
and forth,
pretty freely,
so that there's a lot of
recombination going on across
most of this tree here.
But the housekeeping genes of
these bacteria don't exchange
horizontally so well.
There's a core group of genes,
and they are the genes that are
responsible for energy
metabolism and the construction
of ribosomes and cell walls and
stuff like that,
that actually form a core that
doesn't participate in
horizontal gene exchange.
And if you just concentrate on
that core of genes,
you get a perfectly good
phylogenetic tree.
It forms a gene cluster.
If you include the 30% that are
being horizontally exchanged,
the whole thing gets very
fuzzy.
So that gene cluster definition
is good in bacteria,
if you concentrate on the core
genes, which are housekeeping
genes.
There is a radiation of
salamanders,
Batrachoseps,
in California--well studied by
Dave Wake's lab at Berkeley,
by the way--where there are a
very large number of species and
local forms,
and many of these can only be
recognized if you look at gene
sequences.
So cryptic species are common
in some groups of salamanders.
Cryptic species are also common
in the algae that coral farm.
So reef-building corals have
endosymbiotic commensile algae
that they farm,
and the strain of algae and the
strain of coral have a lot of
cryptic diversity.
You look at it and you can't
tell the difference from the
outside.
There's a lot of diversity like
that, out there in the world.
But this is really one of the
most interesting cases of a
cryptic species,
Tetrahymena.
So this is a ciliate,
and there are ten
morphologically,
completely indistinguishable
forms that had a last common
ancestor about a hundred million
years ago.
So these things are a good
example of stasis.
They still look exactly the
same.
Okay?
However they have diverged a
tremendous amount in their DNA
sequences,
and interestingly even though
they look exactly the same,
the proteins that build those
structures have diverged.
It's like there has been really
strong stabilizing selection to
keep those things looking the
same,
even though the genes,
and the proteins that build
them,
have diverged.
So that's deeply cryptic,
and there's things like that
out there.
So there are cryptic species.
So first, evolutionary
biologists have come up with a
bunch of different species
concepts.
It's like the Hindu tale of the
blind man and the elephant,
and one of them touches the
trunk, calls it a rope;
one of them touches the leg,
calls it a tree.
They're all coming from
slightly different perspectives;
they're emphasizing different
aspects of the process.
What is helpful in thinking
about a species tree is that a
species is a segment of a tree
from start to finish,
and if you're thinking about
gene genealogies,
a species is a population that
is monophyletic and it is
distinct from other similar
populations that are
monophyletic.
The criteria you might want to
think about,
if you want to sit down and
logically distinguish two
populations and call them
different species,
are separation,
cohesion, monophyly and
diagnosibility--
can you really tell differences?
And I've just shown
you--sometimes you can only see
the differences in the DNA
sequences.
And these criteria do mark
stages in the divergence of
lineages.
The genes that are involved in
speciation start off few in
number.
You might only need to be
influencing some aspect of
hybrid inviability or some
aspect of mate choice and
behavior;
perhaps just changing the
frequency of wing fluttering or
something like that.
But then, over time,
the number of genes involved
increase, and other kinds of
reproductive isolation
mechanisms evolve.
And then there are these very
cryptic species that can only be
distinguished as clusters in
genetic space.
Now if you get interested in
this stuff,
here's some--I've stuck this
in, so you'll have this for
reference--
the January 20,2009 issue of
Heredity has ten articles
on the genetics of speciation.
Jerry Coyne and Allen Orr have
a good fairly recent book on
speciation.
You can also,
if you want to,
search for Trevor Price,
Dolph Schluter,
Sergey Gavrilets,
Ulf Dieckmann,
Michael Doebeli;
and you'll pick up books and
papers on recent speciation
ideas.
And next time we're going to
take this basic element of the
Tree of Life,
which is the separation of the
branches,
and start looking at
phylogenetic systematics.